monsieur Leblanc bonsoir bonsoir
Monsieur roi alors là vous allez pas
quand même renommée un autre rapporteur
en lui posant est-ce qu'on doit oui ou
non lancer une enquête publique
j'imagine puis vous avez ouvert la porte
mais soyez essayons d'être plus clair
j'imagine vous allez dire à partir de
maintenant allons-y nous allons tenir
une enquête publique
qu'est-ce que nous avons dit c'est
qu'une enquête publique a jamais été
écartée nous avons demandé à Monsieur
Johnston de regarder et faire des
recommandations il y avait recommandé
contre pour des raisons en termes
d'obligation de protéger des
renseignements de sécurité nationale il
a comme vous avez noté démissionné c'est
un moment que nous croyons important de
diminuer le temps partisan d'essayer de
travailler avec des parties d'opposition
d'autres experts dans le domaine on a
toujours accepté le besoin d'avoir un
processus public ça pourra être une
enquête publique mais une enquête
publique monsieur un peu d'ailleurs à
jamais appeler une enquête publique dans
un cont de sécurité nationale il avait
refusé nous sommes ouverts à le faire à
condition qu'on peut se mettre d'accord
sur des façons de protéger des
renseignements qui va sauver des vies
des Canadiens qui travaillent dans les
agences de renseignements d'essayer de
choisir la meilleure personne ou les
meilleures personnes pour présider une
telle étude publique alors nous sommes
ouverts à toutes ces suggestions là et
franchement monsieur roi moi je suis
encouragé par le temps adopté par les
chefs de l'opposition si on peut trouver
une façon de collaborer mais ce sera
d'ailleurs plus facile à attirer la
bonne personne ou les bonnes personnes à
participer dans ces prochaines étapes
mais est-ce que ce n'est pas maintenant
sur le blanc inévitable vous avez pas de
parce que quel serait les autres
solutions qu'une enquête publique ce
sera pas inévitable monsieur roi si on
peut pas trouver la façon responsable de
faire une enquête publique alors de dire
qu'on veut une enquête publique le Bloc
québécois dit on veut une enquête
publique le Québécois sera jamais au
gouvernement les conservateurs devront
être un peu plus responsables parce
qu'ils savent très bien qui a aucun pays
dans le domaine des renseignements de
sécurité nationale qui va simplement les
mettre dans dans la vitrine publique
cependant si on a les bonnes termes de
référence une façon de protéger des
renseignements la bonne personne ou les
bonnes personnes pour présider d'une
façon responsable qui va donner comme
vous dites la confiance au Canadiens
qu'on est là pour contrer les ingérences
étrangères dans le système démocratique
dans d'autres aspects de la société
carrière moi je suis optimiste mais il
faut être responsable et des solutions
simplistes c'est facile pour
l'opposition c'est un peu plus difficile
pour le gouvernement mais vous êtes
optimiste vous êtes optimiste dans la
mesure où vous pensez que vous allez
vous entendre avec les conservateurs
pour encadrer circonscrire le le lieu
d'examen de cette enquête publique
j'espère que oui il faut protéger ses
renseignements là il faut aussi trouver
la bonne ou les bonnes personnes mais on
est tout à fait ouvert à des idées on va
réfléchir nous-mêmes on comprend le
besoin d'avoir une phase publique à cet
exercice et nous avons hâte dès le
débuter ok mais pourquoi vous me dites
pas
monsieur roi oui il y aura une enquête
publique reste maintenant à nous
entendre avec l'opposition pour arriver
avec quelque chose qui va fonctionner
dans la vraie vie
parce que si on peut pas s'entendre sur
ces questions fondamentales il n'y aura
pas d'enquête publique alors c'est un
peu un chèque anony aigle qu'est-ce qui
est venu avant l'oeuf ou le poulet là
mais moi je vous dis moi je vous dis
monsieur on est tout à fait ouvert avoir
des conversations sérieuses je suis plus
optimiste cette semaine que j'aurais été
il y a deux semaines en terme de leur
désir de diminuer le temps partisan
écoutez les Canadiens sont inquiets avec
raison les communautés de diaspora vous
l'avez bien dit sont inquiets nous
sommes aussi à la recherche de la
meilleure façon de les rassurer de
contribuer à leur confiance et ça
commence avec je pense une diminution du
temps partisan et on est tout à fait
heureux de collaborer là-dessus est-ce
qu'on a pas collectivement perdu
beaucoup de temps autour de tout ça et
qu'à partir du moment où on voyait que
la confiance était érodée chez les
Canadiens plus sondages l'ont montré
depuis quelques mois les gens se
demandaient oui mais que veulent les
Chinois jusqu'où sont-ils allés jusqu'où
sont-ils prêts à aller pour influencer
dans une circonscription ou une autre le
résultat électoral à partir du moment où
vous avez vu quand même un portrait
assez précis pourquoi vous avez pas dit
allons-y avec une enquête publique même
si on sait qu'on pourra pas tout faire
publiquement bien sûr mais allons-y là
on a l'impression que on a tenté de
sauver la chèvre et le chou là écoutez
on n'a pas cet aspect d'un processus
public les prochaines étapes c'est pas
le seul effort que le gouvernement
entreprend pour contrer la gérance
étrangère il y a un comité de
parlementaire de tous les partis
politiques qui étudient la question un
comité d'experts présidé par une
ancienne juge la Cour suprême
responsable pour la surveillance des
institutions de sécurité nationale il y
a on est en train de préparer des
modifications à la Loi des mesures
législatives alors notre travail pour
nous préparer comme pays à affronter
l'ingérence étrangère de s’assurer comme
il se doit que ça peut changer les
résultats électoral continue cette
partie fait cette discussion fait partie
d'un travail franchement qui n'a pas
arrêté du tout mais vous savez que ce
qui n'arrête pas du tout c'est cette
demande jusqu'à la fin des temps pour
une enquête publique si vous ne si vous
ne la donnez pas vous comprenez vous le
savez pour politique depuis plus
longtemps j'étais député d'opposition
aussi de plus de 2 + 2 il faut pas que
ça égale 4 qu'est-ce que vous avez dit
la semaine passée pas nécessairement
alors écoutez c'est on a vu ça
auparavant qu'est-ce qui nous importe
c'est de faire des gestes sérieux qui
vont rassurer les Canadiens et je pense
je pense ça commence avec une
construction à une discussion
constructive avec les parties
d'opposition moi j'espère d'ici une
semaine ou deux monsieur roi moi
j'espère le Parlement devra normalement
conclure à la fin de la semaine
prochaine je pense ce sera dommage si
nous avons pas trouvé une façon d'aller
de d'ici la fin de la semaine prochaine
mais ça va dépendre un peu sur les
facteurs donc d'ici la fin de la semaine
prochaine il faut vous choisissiez la
personne qui va vouloir aller
galoper sur ce cheval aussi c'est ça la
personne ou les personnes les personnes
c'est ça une commission ou un effort de
processus public on a vu ça en
nouvelle-écasse ça peut être plusieurs
personnes de trois personnes mais il
faut choisir les bonnes personnes ou la
bonne personne mais ça commence avec un
consensus je pense chez les partis
politiques merci Dominique Leblanc
ministre fédéral merci à la prochaine
merci à vous monsieur le roi au revoir